XAVIER BARRADE: We are
here to talk to you
about JAM with Chrome.
So when we started the project,
we wanted to make
something that would allow
people to come together around
the Chrome browser.
But, of course, most people
don't treat the Chrome browser
as a thing and they're
interested in things like
food, sport, and in
this case, music.
And we wondered if it would be
possible to let people go on
the website, invite their
friends, and play music in
real time instantly, so
kind of be a rockstar.
So as you can see, there is a
URL on top of the slides, so
you can have a play with the
website while we talk, but
please keep a bit of your
attention for us.
And in a few minutes, we will
make sure to demo, and at the
end of the talk we will
jam with you.
So when we started the project,
things looked quite
simple, but as we progressed,
it got more exciting, but it
also got bigger.
So just so you know, there's
19 different instruments in
JAM, and we have
[? to sample ?]
more than 1,000 songs
from instruments.
And as you can imagine, the
project had its fair share of
complexity and challenges.
So we're going to start to demo
the website so you know
what we're talking about, and
then we will talk about the
main challenges we faced
when we built it.
So this is JAM with Chrome.
I enter the website.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: So as
I enter [INAUDIBLE]
19 different instruments.
You have drums, you have
drum machines.
Different kind of keyboards.
Bass guitars.
And of course, electric
guitars.
I'm going to start
with the drums.
So a JAM room was just created
right now, and now I'm in it.
And as you can see,
the drum is here.
I can make noise.
I can stop and play music
really quickly.
So, of course, it wouldn't be
a jam if I'm alone, so I'm
going to invite a friend.
So I'm going to invite Oskar.
So there's a shortcut that
you can send by instant
messaging to anyone.
So Oskar just entered the
shortcut on his computer, and
as we see, we can already see
that he's going to come.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So I'm going to
play some guitar, because
I'm cooler than you.
XAVIER BARRADE: I like drums.
So Oskar is here.
I'm the drummer, he's the
guitarist, and we're going to
give you a little demo.
[ROCK AND ROLL MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: Thank you.
So because there's 19 different
instruments, you
cannot only play rock and roll,
but you can play lots of
different kinds of music.
So for example, let's play
some tasty techno music.
So I'm taking a keyboard.
Oskar is going to get
a drum machine.
Here we go.
[TECHNO MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: So this is
basically what JAM is.
So this was the easy mode where
you play with patterns,
and there's also play mode--
Pro Mode where you can
play note by note.
So as you can imagine, we had
lots of challenging building
this project.
So today, we're going to talk
about the two main we faced.
So first, let's go to Backstage,
which is auto
creator of virtual JAM room.
[INAUDIBLE]
it is possible and you allow
people to join it.
And then there's the music,
which is, how do you create a
music tool with 19 different
instruments.
All the instrument a
full set of tones.
They have different effects
just using web technology.
So first, we serve
the application.
So as you can see here, the
client is going to request
files from app engine, so he's
going to get to the CSS or
HTML and the Javascript.
And notice the device which are
called from the HTML are
served from cloud storage.
And then each client creates or
joins a jam session, which
is hosted on a Websocket
server.
And this Websocket server in
different data centers across
the world to optimize
the latency.
The App Engine needs to know
what all these Websocket
servers are up to, so what
happens is, every five seconds
every Websocket server is going
to set an outbeat to App
Engine, and this outbeat
contains the IP address, the
zone, the CP load, the
number of game and
the number of clients.
And then, the client is going to
request this listed server
to App Engine.
So App Engine gives them the
free lowest latency server
from each zone.
Then the client is going to
ping the servers, so he's
going to ping them five times
each and he's going to select
the one with the best
performance, so which is the
lowest ping and the least
amount of packets lost.
And when the client selected a
server, informed App Engine of
the selection, the jam
session is created.
And the client gets a shortcut
URL which he an share to
invite people to his session.
And now, I'm going to let Oskar
talk to you about other
client things.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So as any decent
musician will tell you,
one of the most important things
when playing together
is to play in sync for the
music not to stink.
So this is one of the biggest
challenges we had in JAM.
How do we enable people at
totally different locations
across the globe to play
together and hear the same
thing at the same time?
Excuse me.
And an audio system will always
have a certain amount
of latency, and that is the time
from when you press a key
until you actually
hear the notes.
And we really especially have
a lot of latency when the
audio system is distributed
across
continents like in chat.
So we did some experimentation
and we came up with some
numbers, and we say that in the
Pro Mode, we can have up
to 100 milliseconds of latency,
and in the easy mode,
you can accept upwards of 600
milliseconds of latency before
you start feeling like you're
losing control.
And these are actually rather
high numbers when talking
about audio, but the
mind adapts and
compensates rather quickly.
And also, these numbers aren't
impossible to achieve with
Websockets.
So what we had to do was just to
make sure that the clients
are in perfect sync once
they start playing.
So how did we do that?
The first thing you need to
know is, no, we don't swim
actual order files across
the network.
We send events that
trigger play back
on the local clients.
And most of these events needs
to be handled at the exact
same time at all times
for the players to
hear the same thing.
And for this to happen,
we need to have
a common time reference.
So to establish this common time
reference, we developed
the sync algorithm that we run
each time a player leaves or
joins the jam session.
And each client has a local
time, but we need a common
time that these local times
can be related to.
So when we say play at this
time, everyone knows which
time we mean.
And before I move on, thinking
about time can be very
confusing, but this will be
recorded and available
afterwards.
So don't sweat it if and
when you get lost.
So to sync the clients, we start
off by making 10 sets of
pings to the WebSocket
server, like so.
First, the client sends a
message with its own local
time, and the server receives
this and sends back the
received time as well as the
local time on the server.
And for each time we
do this, the client
calculates two values.
The time it took for the message
to go back and forth,
which is the travel time.
And the difference between the
local time and time on the
server, which is the
time offset.
And when we have done this 10
times, we calculate the mean
value for the travel times,
which is this client's
latency, and send that
value to the server.
We then calculate the mean value
for the time offsets,
which is the difference between
the local time and the
server time.
And when all the clients have
done this and sent their
latency to the server, the
server sends out the highest
latency reported for all
the clients to use.
And this means that all clients
should be able to
handle events at the exact same
time since they have the
same latency as the client with
the poorest connection,
and they all know the time of
their own local time in
relation to the server time.
So now that we have a common
time reference, we can start
sending messages
back and forth.
And so let's see how we
calculate these times.
So when an event is to be
broadcasted over the network,
we calculate a local event time,
it should happen now,
and then we add the server
offset to that time, and then
we have the event time expressed
in server time.
And the server doesn't really
care what an event-- what it's
all about, it just broadcasts
it to all
the connected clients.
And then, when it's received
on another client, that
client's server offset is
subtracted and they have the
event time expressed in that
client's local time.
And that's where the
magic happen.
On the client from which the
event originates, the event is
scheduled locally using the same
calculations, but without
sending the event over the
network, which makes sure that
the time will always be
consistent for what the player
does herself, even if
the network acts up.
And if the player is alone in a
jam session, the application
goes into a solo mode where no
events are sent across the
network and the latency is set
as low as possible, which
enables the users to play the
instruments with great precision.
XAVIER BARRADE: So one of the
things that was important for
us when we worked on JAM was
that anybody could come and
play instantly, and we also
wanted a real musician, who
can play real music, to be
able to do it on JAM.
So I'm going to demo easy mode
quickly, and then Oskar is
going to explain to you
how we made it.
So this is easy mode
work with patterns.
Imagine the tracks and each time
you click on a different
part of the drum, it's going
from one track to another.
So for example--
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So what you
just heard is not a
prerecorded piece, it's
a sampler playing the
notes in real time.
And I'll talk about the sampler
in a bit, but first,
let's talk about
these patterns.
So the concept of a pattern
is really simple.
It's just a collection of
events that contain
information about what note
should we play that together
make up a piece of music.
And we used MIDI as the format
for expressing what these
patterns should sound like.
And by parsing these MIDI files,
the application got a
collection of events, the
information about what notes
should be played and when, and
any other meet data needed to
make the sampler play
the notes properly.
So we start by downloading these
MIDI files to the client
and parse them there, and
keeping the patterns as MIDI
gives us an easy workflow since
our music editors can
use the tools that they
are already used to.
And also MIDI is a lightweight
format when compared to
keeping the patterns as
JSON for example.
So when we have parsed these
patterns and we're ready to
start playing, we thought a
pattern engine that loops,
much like a game engine loops,
if that's more familiar to
you, and then the engine looks
ahead into a point in the
future, maybe 30 milliseconds
or so, for events in the
pattern that we're playing that
will happen between now
and that point in the future.
And if there are any such
events, we send those to the
sampler that are playing
the pattern.
Now, we don't send all the
events that come from the
pattern over the network.
We'd rather just send events
that start playback on all the
clients at the same
time instead.
And when a player, for example,
changes the stream on
the guitar, an event for that
interaction is sent to all the
connected clients, and we have
a logic unit that calculates
which pattern we should switch
to based on what sting and
where on that string interaction
happened.
So our pattern engine allows
us to find where we want to
add the new pattern, be it the
next bar, next beat, or as in
JAM, as soon as possible.
And if you think of the pattern
engine as a musician,
and the logic engine as the
conductor, one can imagine the
logic engine replacing the sheet
music for the pattern
engine from the old pattern to
the new one and the pattern
engine is no more
wiser for it.
So when the pattern engine then
looks into the future for
upcoming events, it sees events
from the new pattern,
and we get the seamless
transition
between those patterns.
XAVIER BARRADE: So as I said,
we wanted a good musician to
be able to play what they wanted
so this was a really
challenging part of the tour
because I need to demo the Pro
Mode to you.
So it's basically, like on
almost every music software,
one key I get a one note, so I'm
going to play you a little
non-copyrighted piece
of music.
It may be really bad.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So as you heard
Pro Mode takes more
skill from the user, but it's
much easier for the developer.
So instead of having a logic
unit and a pattern engine, we
simply create the same kind
of events based on user
interaction with the
UI instead .
And unlike the events that come
from the patterns, these
interaction events are all
sent one by one over the
network, but still scheduled
locally from the client from
which it came.
So let's talk about
the sampler.
A sampler is an instrument
that plays
prerecorded audio files.
And in its most simple form, we
assign one sample per key
on a keyboard.
In JAM, we took this concept one
step further, and used the
playback rates property of the
audio source nodes to pitch
the samples, and this allows
us to use fewer samples to
cover bigger frequency ranges.
And this cuts the number of
samples we have to use by a
lot and also the rate of the
application obviously.
And the events for starting
notes that we've been sending
back and forth over the network
and generated by a
pattern, so user interaction,
all end up at the
sampler in the end.
And these events contain a start
time, a stop time, a
velocity, and what
note to play.
And when we get one of these
events, the sampler checks
which sample relates to this
note that we're going to play.
So in this case, we're looking
for an F note, and we can see
that sample S3 is the
one we should play.
We can then start it with the
proper playback rate setting
at the given start time.
And this method of feeding the
sampler events gives us a neat
separation of code and
instant reusability.
The sampler just smiles and
plays whatever it's told, just
like a drummer.
So, of course, we didn't
stop there in JAM.
Since we get a velocity property
with our events, we
can add another layer of realism
by having multiple
variations of the same sample.
So here we have three different
velocity levels of
samples stacked on each other,
which means that when we
recorded these instruments, we
had to make three samples for
each note at different
velocities.
So if you get a note with a low
velocity, we choose a soft
sample, and a higher velocity,
we choose the harder sample.
And to illustrate, we're going
to play you a piano, and what
you're going to hear is first, a
low velocity note and then a
high velocity note.
As soon as Xavier finds
the right file.
Here we go.
XAVIER BARRADE: The piano
sounds like this.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So let's
play that again.
First, the soft sample
then a hard sample.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So to give you
another example of the level
of detail that went
into the project.
Let's have a look at playing
the guitar in Pro Mode.
So if you first play one note
on one string, and then play
another note on the same string
while still keeping the
first key pressed down, you get
another variation of the
sample called a puller note if
there are any guitarists here,
and it sounds like this.
[GUITAR NOTES PLAYING]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So what you
first heard are two notes
played normally, and then, on
the second round, it's one
note played normally and
then a puller note.
[GUITAR NOTES PLAYING]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: And these are
the kind of nuances that are
really important to create
realistic instruments, but
it's also the kind of details
that eats up all of your
developing time if you're
not careful.
Take it from me.
And so on top of this, each
instrument has two sets of
effects that are generated with
Web Audio in real time, .
And Xavier is going to give
you a demo of that.
XAVIER BARRADE: Yeah, so the
effect is one of the coolest
parts in JAM, especially if you
consider that it was done
entirely using Web Audio.
So to demonstrate, I'm going to
pick the best instrument of
the website, which is
the metallic guitar.
So if you play a metal guitar
without any effect, it doesn't
sound very rock and roll.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: But you can
see that I use a slight
[INAUDIBLE] of distortion
up to the max, and now.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: And if I want a
pretty good spacey feeling,
I can just put the flanger up.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So first, let's
talk a bit basic about
what it is.
So to explain Web Audio for
someone who's never used it, I
think that the concept of an
assembly line often brings the
bird into nest.
So you have an assembly line
with agents that produce and
refine a product, and
in Web Audio, these
agents are called nodes.
And there are nodes for
generating the raw material,
or audio that is, and nodes
for modifying the audio.
And this is just like
the keynote.
Sorry.
And so there are quite a
manageable number of these
nodes natively in Web Audio,
but for more advanced audio
applications, you might want
to create your own.
And to enable us to do this in
JAM, we created this model
that we used, which allows us to
use our custom nodes, much
like the native nodes.
So we have an input and an
output property, and we have a
connect and disconnect method.
And that's it.
So to use it, we do exactly the
same as we do with normal
nodes , with the exception that
we need to connect to the
custom nodes input properly
instead of the node itself.
And the conception model
is really easy and
it looks like this.
So here we have a gain node
and another gain node, and
then the custom node
in the middle.
So using this model, we can
create our samplers or maybe,
our own audio effects.
So let's create a
delay effect.
So the structure is really
similar to the basic model.
We have just added a delay
node, and a wet level and
feedback at gain nodes.
So the delay node delays the
signal and sends it to the wet
level gain node and the
feedback gain node.
And the feedback sends back a
diminished version of the
signal to the delay node, which
then delays it again,
and we have a feedback loop.
And the wet level node lets us
change how much of the delayed
signal we want to send
to the output and mix
with the clean signal.
And the codes that implement
this, looks like this, and I
don't expect you to
see what it says.
But let's just say that it's
really condensed considering
all the work that is being
done behind the scenes.
So we simply create the nodes
and then set the values for
the delay and feedback that we
want, and then we make sure
that the routing looks
as it does in the
model and that's it.
No math needed.
And the results sounds
like this.
[GUITAR NOTE]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: That's dry.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: And that's
with the delay.
[GUITAR NOTE]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: And it's a
really big room so I didn't
really have a difference,
but the second
one is a bit delayed.
And this is a lengthy article
that I wrote on the subject
that you can read at
age HTML5Rocks.com.
But if you felt this was way too
much work, we release the
effects that we use in
JAM as tuna JS for
your comfort and pleasure.
So please feel free to
hack away and give
us more pulled requests.
There are still many effects
that need to be made.
And that's what I have to say.
XAVIER BARRADE: So JAM was a
really interesting project to
work on because when we started,
we were excited by
Websockets, by Google Compute,
by Go, by Web Audio.
And we already had people we
managed to take demo and make
it something that lots of people
used and connected
over, and used the web in
a pretty different way.
So to give you an idea, we had
more than 3 million visits
with an average visit duration
of more than 10 minutes, and
we would like to conclude by
showing you a little movie we
did when we launched
the application.
And it features the most
famous musician on the
internet, which is
Keyboard Cat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: Thank you.
So if anybody has any questions,
you can go to the
two microphones on the sides.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
Is this on?
XAVIER BARRADE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for that
really, really amazing
application.
The biggest question mark in
my mind are custom nodes in
the Web Audio API.
Now, I've seen it before,
including at last year's
Google I/O, but it seems like
that's a really deep down
magic kind of black box thing.
How do I learn how
to start becoming
proficient with those?
OSKAR ERIKSSON: That's a
really good question.
Well, as you said, it is a
black box and the audio
communities--
it's very technical, but there
is this one site, which I
can't remember from my head that
has a lot of algorithms
and structures ready to use.
And if you follow me
on Google+, I will
post a link for you.
That's a good way to start.
And I can post some books
too, I think.
So that's the best I can
give you right now.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
James Hardik.
I had a question, how long or
how often, I guess, are you
doing the time syncing.
I don't know if you
mentioned that.
But if you do it just at the
beginning and for some reason,
the latency of a person's
internet connection changes,
how often do you do that and
keep that kind of up to date
per client?
OSKAR ERIKSSON: We actually
do two rounds of pings.
First when we join a session,
and that has nothing to do
with the syncing of the clients,
just rather selecting
the servers.
And then we do it again to
actually sync the clients, and
we do this just once.
But every time someone leaves or
joins the jam, and then we
do it for all of the clients.
So we just assume that the
latency will be consistent as
long as the same players are in
the jam, and this actually
works out rather well.
We tested us into
that assumption.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: Did I do that?
XAVIER BARRADE: Yeah,
I took a screenshot.
So if there's not any more
questions, we are going to put
a shortcut on the screen and
the three first people who
enter the shortcut
will be able to
jam live on the screen.
If I can.
The [? bell ?] is
not going up.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So only people
with really good
eyesight can jam.
XAVIER BARRADE: Interesting.
I know.
So this is the screenshot
I just--
Now that I closed the website,
I have to take a new one.
Sorry, guys.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: So
you can still ask
questions if you want.
XAVIER BARRADE: Yeah, if you
have more questions while
[INAUDIBLE].
Ah, someone is joining
over there.
OK, so I'm going to
zoom that in.
It's case sensitive, yes.
Extra challenge.
So it's only going to work
if you have a laptop.
Web Audio is not yet activated
on mobile.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
XAVIER BARRADE: Yeah, but we
haven't optimized the website
for mobile yet, so it's going
to work better on laptop.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: Give it
a try, you never know.
XAVIER BARRADE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You went through
before how the sampling you
needed to do for each of
these, you said 19
instruments.
What would the process be like
at some point in the future.
Obviously, not a feature you
have right now, but at some
point in the future, where you
might allow somebody to
attempt to get a new instrument
into your system.
What kinds of things would they
need to upload in order
for that to be a possibility?
XAVIER BARRADE: This
is one of--
When we work on this project,
we had lots of things we--
it was an experimental project
so there was lots of things we
could have done or not, and this
is one of the things that
we might investigate.
So if you follow me on Google+,
if you'll search for
Xavier Barrade on Google+, I can
come back to you on this
question later.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Second, short--
I was working on a similar
project but not with musical
instruments, actually attempting
to do voice
recording in a group.
And of course, doing that we
can't rely on MIDI, to resolve
the latency issues.
The attempt was to actually do
dramatic recording with people
hearing each other in remote
locations as opposed to
everybody recording individually
not getting to
hear each other when they
were doing their pieces.
Did you try any other ways of
dealing with the latency, even
ones you abandoned that might
help people trying to resolve
the problem in other ways?
OSKAR ERIKSSON: Well, actually,
when singing, it's
even more--
latency is even a bigger issue,
and I don't want to say
it's not possible, but I would
say it's really hard today.
I don't really have any
great ideas for you.
It's a really good problem, and
a really good question.
So let me know if you come
up with anything.
XAVIER BARRADE: OK, so I think
the band is ready.
Let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER BARRADE: [INAUDIBLE]
guitar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OSKAR ERIKSSON: Yeah, I would
pay to hear that.
That's a good one.
XAVIER BARRADE: That's
pretty good.
So as you see, even in easy
mode, it kind of requires a
bit of skill to come to
a nice piece of music.
So thank you, guys.
I think we're done.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Question, did you
check out Justin Frankel, the
guy who did Winamp?
He made a collaboration
program where it puts
everybody like a bar ahead so
that you can jam in a groove
instead of repeat like that so
you're actually always playing
in real time with the music, so
is your latency for what's
being recorded.
But what you hear is everybody
else's previous bar or like
four bars so it's
configurable.
So I don't know if
you saw that?
From your expression,
probably not, but
that's also a cool approach.
OSKAR ERIKSSON: That sounds
hard to play a
real song though .
If you have to play
one bar ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
OSKAR ERIKSSON: Cool.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.